all right before we get into it i want
to thank surfsharkvpn for sponsoring
this video
you know in an ocean of online content
there's a lot of websites and little
crabs that
take your info without you even knowing
it but you can swim under their radar
using surfsharkvpn
or virtual private network you can stop
websites from tracking your info and
selling targeted ads to you
nothing is creepier than when you have a
conversation with a crustacean about
something and then it pops up in your
ads
plus with serp sharks alert id
production you'll get an alert
when some little jerk manta ray is
trying to break into your email you know
one of my favorite features about surf
shark
is that you can see content not
available in your area
that means your viewing isn't bound by
your geography
just log in with surfshark and you can
get access to videos that aren't
normally available to you
look if you want both protection and
freedom online
click the link in the description and
use code star talk
it not only gives you 83 percent
off the regular price but also three
months of totally free service surf
shark
offers a 30 day money back guarantee so
there's
no risk to try this out for yourself
thanks surf shark
[Music]
chuck do you do you have any idea how
small
molecules are well seeing uh as
i can't see them i'm going to say n i do
not
right and even if you did say you knew i
would say you didn't know
i'm just pulling rank here i'm just
saying molecules i mean think about it
our understanding of the existence of
atoms did not even
come into age until the 20th century
atoms were
still a hypothesis all right that
there'd be this sort of smallest unit of
a material
called the atom by the way the word atom
from the greek means indivisible
so they imagined that there was some
individual minimal part of a thing
but of course we break out bust atoms
all the time so
no they're not indivisible but we kept
the term right we kept the term atom to
describe
the electrons protons and neutrons the
classical particles you learn about in
in high school chemistry and maybe
physics
so uh so molecules are
um i i could give an example
okay and this is my favorite example of
them all
so uh think about how much water there
is in the world
in all the oceans okay and if you go in
the middle of the ocean it's
miles deep okay the titanic was like
three and a half mile i forgot the exact
number multiple miles
below earth's surface okay
that's a lot of water it's a lot of work
and what is the water molecule h2o
h2o okay so two hydrogen one oxygen h2o
so this is salts and dissolved salts and
fish poop and stuff like that but
by it's basically h2o all over the world
all right i love that you threw in the
fish poop
[Laughter]
i'm so proud of you i'm thank you
that's the juvenile part the
eight-year-olds will want to know that
yes
there's also fish poop right in the
ocean
so where else does it go right um and
just to recite the
title of a book they may have grown up
on everything poops
wow actually an italian kid story that
uh
translated i got what the translated
version of it yeah and it shows it's
just a story
it's for little kids because they poop
and they know they poop and they're
fascinated by it
and it's just an account that everybody
poops and all the fish poop in the ocean
okay they don't go
onto land to poop yeah i i read that
book to my daughter she thought it was
crappy
i couldn't help it all right so they
don't have outhouses on the land right
right
that would be amazing though
oh god you just gave me the best thought
in the world where a fish a
fish just shows up at somebody's
apartment door or house and just lets
one go and goes
how do you like it put it into your own
house
because we put all our sewage put them
into theirs right
how great now you know how it feels
all right so i now take a glass
and fill it with water okay
a regular cup a cup okay that you might
drink water out of
okay fill it up so stare at that cup
and i will tell you that there are more
molecules of water in that cup
then there are cups of water in all the
world's oceans
holy crap wow
okay now the reason why i couched it
that way
is because that leads to fascinating
conclusions
okay if this cup of water has more
molecules than there are cups of water
in
all the world that means when i drink
this cup of water
and it comes out of me eventually right
through snot spit
sweat right whatever it'll come out of
you and it goes
back into the environment
okay you have excreted
enough molecules to populate
every single cup of water that is ever
drawn from the oceans
just got to give it enough time okay
so this moisture goes back into the
environment and
the molecules that pass through my
kidneys are now working their way
around the world give it enough time
i can guarantee you that there will be
some molecules in that next cup of water
you scoop
that pass through my kidneys
so i get to make the following statement
every glass of water you drink
contains molecules that pass through the
kidneys of abe lincoln
uh genghis khan uh joan of arc
uh pick your favorite historical
character
okay have shared water molecules with
that person
well all i can say is that somehow
you've done it neil you've done it
you've made it so i am never again going
to drink water
i think i did i ran the calculation it's
about a hundred molecules
per per cup of water that's how that's
how small molecules are
that's that's my point that's the whole
point of this exercise
like i'll give you one more you ready go
for it all right
there are more molecules
in a breath of air okay this would be
now nitrogen molecules
mostly nitrogen and then oxygen okay
n2 and o2 because they're each in a
molecular form a little bit of argon and
some carbon dioxide but it's
predominantly nitrogen and oxygen
there are more molecules air molecules
and a breath of air you take
then there are breaths of air in all
of the earth's atmosphere oh gotcha
right
okay so it means when you
exhale right air that comes
out of your lungs scatters back into the
air and there are plenty of air
molecules
to scatter into every other breath that
will ever be taken
in the future history of the world wow
so you're not only sharing water
molecules with people who've come before
you
you're sharing air molecules that you
have breathed
that's how small they are this is my
point
and and so so
um it's remarkable that we were able to
discover them at all
much less the atoms that they comprise
what you do is you look at things that
they do
that you can see through microscopes
electron microscopes this sort of thing
and you say the only understanding of
this is if the atoms got together and
made a molecule
but nobody's holding up a molecule here
take this and plug it in this way
all right there's some ways to image
molecules we're on the
verge of that there's something called
quantum
construction there's a bet there's a
real term for it but what they're
actually doing is
if you get tools small enough you can
take a molecule and put it here and add
an atom
and build things at a molecular level
the way carpenters
or construction workers assemble
buildings by putting bricks
together okay that's freaky and scary
it's a little freaky and scary right if
you have a brick that's a smaller part
of a larger hole
you just need tools that can maneuver
the bricks right if i want to make a
molecule that's never been made before
and i make sure that it's a stable
molecule how am i going to do that do i
just put all the m and jiggle them
maybe they won't want to do that on
their own but if i make it happen
with with quantum tweezers
then i can start making molecules and
you might even be able to make
life at that point and not wait for it
to happen by chance
so so a frontier is our ability
to manipulate those things that we could
never see
interesting that is amazing
that so but but why think of it not as
creepy that you're you're
you're drinking water that passed
through someone else's kidneys no
i don't i don't ever want to have that
thought again i'm so sorry that you
brought it up
you're gonna stop drinking water let me
tell you the whole time you've been
talking i've been wanting to drink this
right here i'm not doing it you're not
doing it i'm not doing it now
it's over i just can't i can't drink
water anymore
you know i have to go my whole life now
it's go it's gonna have to be great
kool-aid because guess what
i know that i'm not sharing that with
with jesus and genghis khan because i
didn't have kool-aid i know that jesus
and genghis khan did not have kool-aid
so now i can only drink grape kool-aid
thank you
[Laughter]
so um yeah so it's just they're
impressively little
yeah and here we are in our big
macroscopic scale i mean think about
most of the history of research and
investigation and trying to understand
the world around us
we were anchored to our five senses as
the one and onl
as the only means of of measuring and
decoding what the world was doing around
us
right and forget molecules we didn't
even know about
bacteria or viruses all right and
so you catch a disease you find somebody
to blame or you were a sinner
you know you had other explanations for
it none of which
bore any correspondence with an
objective reality
that we would not then glean until many
many centuries
later i don't know what you're talking
about we still haven't learned that
lesson
oh that's true people say
yeah people don't know how to relate to
viruses yeah they still don't know
oh man oh that is really cool though
yeah so so
so there it is i i have nothing more to
add to that oh and by the way this is
how you get
um avogadro's number that's that's
that's
the count of molecules right
in in a mole what's what's the mole
number
yeah so you have to look at the element
on the periodic table or
the the atomic weight of the molecule
itself
right and so let's look at carbon if
carbon has
is its atomic number is 12. the natural
carbon has
six elec six protons and six neutrons
so a mole of carbon is 12
grams of carbon gotcha okay a mole
of of silicon would be 18 grams
of silicon okay so because it's atomic
number is 18.
right i'm sorry i'm sorry i didn't say
this right carbon's atomic number is six
because you're counting protons but its
atomic weight is six plus six
you get 12. okay all right so that's six
protons six neutrons
so my only point here is uh
so you can ask if you have a mole of a
substance
how many molecules is that okay
so 12 grams you know 12 gram is not very
much no it's not
okay it's it's not so 12 grams
it's a third of an ounce of carbon how
many molecules in that well it's
avogadro's number of molecules
and that's 6.022 just call it six
times 10 to the 23rd power right okay
cool 23rd that's insane
that's insane yeah yes
i mean that's i i i mean that's really
not a conceivable number
i was 100 times bigger than the number
of stars in the observable universe yeah
i was going to say that it's not a
conceivable
number because like the 23 zeros
like what's up you can't say oh it's
twice as big as this other thing you
already know about
exactly there's no because there is no
other thing it just doesn't
there's just nothing that it's crazy
that's crazy
right right this is a problem when you
are dealing with extremes and we
confront this all the time in
astrophysics right
um how do you talk about the biz the
biggest explosion
in the universe how do you measure
that right you know usually you measure
something because you have other things
that are bigger
other things that are smaller and then
you say with somewhere in there and then
you triangulate on it and now i
understand but if it's more than
anything you've seen before it becomes a
challenge to explain it's it's a it's a
philosophical issue of communication
right and and our own physiology's
ability to
to uh come to terms with things that
fall far outside of our life experience
but anyhow chuck that's about it oh man
that was good that was great
and please do drink water
never again great kool-aid only cool
never again kool-aid has water in it
just i thought i'd
just but then it's flavored
now i'm drinking your flavored kidney
water i i get it you're guaranteeing
that no one before you had passed
that kool-aid flavor through their
kidneys there you go
the kool-aid headquarters they're phd
chemist inventing this stuff there you
go i got one thing to say to that
oh yeah okay
all right chuck we're done here all
right all right be good
neil degrasse tyson four star talk keep
looking up
[Music]